and now I'd like to introduce you to our
speakers today professors reader pop hat
and professor Christine Suhani so
professor Rita blow pad is a clinical
associate professor in the department of
health research and policy and the
co-director of the master's program and
clinical research and epidemiology at
Stanford University she has a PhD in
epidemiology and also holds master's
degrees and biostatistics and physical
therapy Rita has taught several
methodology and data analysis courses at
Stanford for more than a decade and has
received several excellence in teaching
and mentoring awards from the graduate
program in epidemiology and at the
Sanford Medical School dr. papad
specializes in teaching and mentoring
medical and allied health professionals
she has a strong interest in developing
curriculum and implementing new
instruction models and recently
developed a blended course in
epidemiology and biostatistics for
Stanford medical students she is also
interested in neurodegenerative diseases
and studies the role of genetic and
environmental factors and Parkinson's
disease and lateral scoliosis so
professor Christine Suhani
is an associate professor here at
Stanford University she also code
directs Stanford's ph.d program in
epidemiology and clinical research
Kristin teaches statistics and writing
and performs research in sports medicine
she also writes about statistics and
science for a range of different
audiences professor sighnaghi has
received several teaching awards
including Stanford's 2018 Biosciences
Award for Excellence in graduate
teaching she has authored the Health
column body muse for Allure magazine for
a decade and she is also the statistical
direct editor for The Journal of
physical medicine and rehabilitation and
she authors a statistics column
statistically speaking for this journal
she teaches two popular massive open
online courses including statistics and
medicine on open edx and writing in the
sciences on open EDX and Coursera and
now I'd like to turn the floor over to
Kristin Narita thank you well welcome
everyone good to have you all so what
I'm hoping to do in the next few minutes
today is to give you an idea
of the kind of content and material
you're likely to see in the certificate
program in clinical research and
epidemiology so just briefly when we
talk about clinical research and epi
what we're often interested in is in
understanding or evaluating a
relationship between an exposure and an
outcome and the exposure could be
anything it could be a genetic factor a
non genetic factor a drug or you know
any sort of lifestyle factor so here are
three examples that just hit the news
last week so I can have researched this
in preparation for today's webinar so
here's the first one
does alcohol consumption during
breastfeeding is that associated with
poor cognitive outcomes in children
another example that we saw recently and
last week was actually researchers here
at Stanford where they examined whether
acetyl l-carnitine I'm just gonna call
it lack whether these levels and this is
a chemical by the way which we all
produce naturally in the body and it's
four important for brain function and
they wanted to see if this was
associated with increased risk of major
depressive disorder which I will just
refer to as depression and here's a
third example this is sort of a stem
cell therapy example where do induced
pluripotent stem cells can they help
sort of cure so to speak or reduce the
symptoms alleviate the symptoms in
Parkinson's disease so as you can see
here we've got three examples of three
very different kinds of exposures we've
got alcohol consumption which is of
course a lifestyle factor a factor it's
an exogenous sort of risk factor we've
got a naturally you know endogenous
chemical like the lac and then we've got
sort of stem cell therapy let's
elaborate a little bit let's look at
this example with lac levels in MD D so
as I said these are researchers from
Stanford the study was published in the
Proceedings of National Academy of
Sciences so this got picked up got a lot
of news attention you can see there's
one article talking about where the low
lac levels is a new biomarker so with
this new interest in precision medicine
the role of biomarkers and in sort of
predicting who's at risk for certain
diseases this is sort of an interesting
angle to look at this particular
chemical with and then we've got a blood
test that could be used for treatment so
you've got a prediction sort of
potential as well as a treatment
potential well very briefly what the
researchers did is they looked at lack
levels in the plasma among a group of
patients who had MD D and a group that
did so the blue dots are the ones who
don't have major depressive disorders
and the red dots stand for people who
actually do have major depressive
disorder and you can see that lack
levels are lower in those with MD D
compared to those who don't have it and
we won't get into the statistics that
you can see it's a highly statistically
significant p-value of 0.02 you know so
you might say oh wow you know should you
be compelled should we all go out and
start taking the supplement which by the
way is available in sort of health food
stores so would you be recommending this
to your relatives or friends who may
have MDT hmm I hope you all would be
skeptical because before we see and
decide whether we should start taking
this supplement we want to ask the
question and this is what we hope to
train everybody who's in our program to
first ask the question well how was this
association between lack levels and MD D
evaluated so you we logically think of
this as three steps the first step is a
research methodology then we go to step
two which is how was the analysis done
and finally how do we make now there our
interpretation based on the results and
how the study was conducted so let me
elaborate a little bit on step one since
my colleague dr. Suhani will elaborate
on step two which is the statistical
analysis so in step one when we talk
about research methodology simply put
we're asking three basic things how was
the study done so what was the study
design who was in the study
what was a study population and finally
what measurements were made so I want
you to think about okay well if you were
interested in this relationship between
lack levels and MTD what do you think
might be an appropriate way to actually
design this study now I'm going to leave
out the clinical trial because you know
we're not going to start randomizing
people we first want to see evidence
from observational studies so okay let
me help you out and I'm sure you all
this is you know you can probably come
up with this design let's say you're the
investigator you're going to get a group
of people who are that you know don't
have MD D now and we won't get into
inclusion exclusion criteria but you
would choose your cohort of people you
will then measure their lack levels at
baseline and then you will follow them
forward in time and then you'll evaluate
who develops MD D versus not sorry guys
I know the guys lying flat are not meant
to be dead it's just too you know
illustrate the two different groups a
group that developed MD D and a group
that didn't by the way a fancy word for
this design is a prospective cohort
study and we like these studies and you
can see why because causalities in the
right direction what I mean by that is
that the exposure that is lack levels
comes first followed by the outcome MD D
so if we do find an association at least
the design helps us explore whether this
is causal in nature as I mentioned
that's a fancy term for this design now
here's another way to do it and maybe
some of you came up with this design so
you're still the investigator but now
you start with a group of people who
have MD D and a group of people who
don't have MD D and then you go back and
then you try to determine their lac
levels either taken at that
cross-section in time or maybe from
samples that were stored previously now
let me ask you this among these two
designs oh by the way this is the case
control study some of these two designs
which one do you think is a stronger one
to sort of bear more credibility that
that there is a causal link what I think
we would all say the prospective cohorts
what if I told you what these
researchers did was actually a case
control study so you see before you get
all starry-eyed and blown away by the
statistics and the p-value you really
have to evaluate how the study was done
now I'm not trying to say that the
researchers say that there is a causal
link so I want to be mindful that they
you know we're correct in the way they
interpreted the data but for most of us
when we look at the literature we just
focus on you know the statistical piece
and the p-values and less so on how the
met what the methods were that generated
these results and in my courses I
focused a lot on this methodology piece
because we can see that certain study
designs lend themselves better to
understanding causal associations we
also want to ask other questions so this
is about measurements how was major
depressive disorder ascertained were
reliable and valid methods used was it
used in a standardized manner in in all
study puck in the entire study sample
how are the lack level measures what the
assays reliable how about validity does
an a lack level taken at one
cross-section of time is that truly
reflective of one's you know exposure to
these lack levels over time so you see
it raises a ton of questions which we
need to keep in mind in order to
correctly interpret the study findings
and then because it's an observational
study we were worried about other
confound errs as well so what we have to
really be able to separate is causation
versus Association we can see non causal
explanations that can generate spurious
associations between an exposure and
outcome so in this course we also spend
time talking about sources of study
biases that can produce these furious
associations when actually there's
nothing going on between the exposure
and the outcome so we first have to
actually rule out all non causal
explanations and then ask the question
okay well is there evidence to support a
causal association between the exposure
and outcome and to
cook quick points just because you
observe a statistically or clinically
significant effect doesn't mean there is
a real effect and the converse is also
true just because you fail to observe or
statistically or a clinically
significant effect it doesn't mean that
a real effect is absent the study
methodology could be so flawed that you
actually fail to pick up a signal of
flawed study methodology you can also do
you know what we see above where it can
produce a spurious effect so we kind of
have to be detectives clinical research
detectives and what as detectives we do
is we try to figure out how much was a
study finding influenced by bias and
what's bias it's any deviation of truth
beyond chance error so these are
systematic errors by the investigators
and sampling collecting or interpreting
data so this is how we sort of culminate
the course where you know we've learned
about the methodology and I give
students papers to read they read it we
look at the study findings if we believe
that the study has some truth in it then
we say the study has internal validity
and then we move on and we ask Oh could
this be useful in clinical practice or
in designing sort of the next sort of
research a question on the other hand if
we determine that there's too much bias
in this study and that it really affects
the validity and we are skeptical
whether that's truth in the study we
stop right there but in the previous
scenario if the study does have some
truth then you can ask about
generalizability or external validity
and this is where we ask the question
can what we found in our sample be
applicable to the study population
beyond that you know and where we want
to apply these findings to but if we
messed up the way we samples and the way
we actually studied and came up with the
study sample that generated the results
then while the study may be valid it may
not be generalizable to the population
beyond that was included in that
particular study so true
or false I get this question a lot
because not everybody is going to be
doing prospective data collection and be
designing these studies and you may be
working with existing data so here's the
question I get we don't need to worry
about study designer measurements
because we're using an existing data
base or a data source and information
has already been collected we just need
to understand how to do the data
analysis of course I'm setting you up
because this is false and I hope we've
given us you know I've been able to give
you a small example to show you why it's
not even if it's just secondary data
that you're using you still within that
need to ask yourself about measurements
about whether it's the right data base
to be answering a particular exposure
outcome relationship and whether you can
even get to answering the question about
causation so in a nutshell when we want
to examine an exposure outcome
relationship
step one is research methodology the
statistics is very important too because
epidemiology and clinical research is a
quantitative field so you have the
methods and you need the statistics and
the end analytic approaches to be able
to quantify the relationship between the
exposure and outcome but the methodology
informs the statistics and in this
series in the certificate program - you
will learn about statistical approaches
that can actually help you you know
account for some of the weaknesses in
the study methodology things like on
founding and control for those types of
variables and finally we need both the
methodology and the analysis to help us
with the interpretation so clinical
research and epidemiology for whom you
know who should be studying this so if
any of you are interested in research or
studies that involve human subjects
either active data collection or
recorded data this might be the one for
you
so what skills will you learn these are
just some that you know I've put here
I'm sure there are others and dr.
Santana can chime in but here are some
of the skills that you hope students
just in our program but in our
certificate program we'll learn how to
critically evaluate a published paper
how do you conduct peer review of a
research manuscript or a grant so some
of you may be serving in these roles and
it's a huge contribution to the
scientific community to know how to
critically you know do a peer review of
a manuscript or a grant which is all
done on a volunteer basis by the way how
to develop a study protocol for an
observational study or a clinical trial
so for those of you who are in the
trenches who are helping pis design
studies conduct studies our courses will
help you develop these type of study
protocols to assist the bi or perhaps
you are the pide who's developing a
protocol to help you develop analytic
approach appropriate for the proposed
study design to conduct data analysis of
course with the help of the courses that
my colleague eared dr. sonali teaches
and how to interpret results so very
briefly in our master's program where we
have three four courses in the
methodology series you've seen that the
numbers here HRP 225 226 251 the
description is given below in the
certificate program we're asking
students to just require to take two of
them that's 225 and 251 so what do these
courses cover HRP 225 which is designing
conduct of clinical and epidemiological
research studies we cover descriptive
epidemiology sampling methods
reliability and validity of measurements
analytic analytic study designs their
strengths and limitations or sort of
court case control cross-sectional
studies we talk about measures of
Association things that you might be
familiar with like odds ratios risk
ratios hazard ratios sample size
estimation how do you power your studies
how many people do you need to study a
relationship sources of bias confounding
we talk about interactions we talk about
causal inference we do a systematic
critique as a culmination of having
learned all of these concepts and we
also touch upon diagnostic tests and
screening the spring quarter class which
is called HRP 251
focus on clinical trials exclusively so
you must have an intervention then you
can randomize now we also touch upon
early phase trial so let me just go
through some of the topics that we cover
in this in this course oh we've got
design issues how to think about
outcomes and how to select them
surrogate versus hard clinical endpoints
we discuss phase 1 phase 2 study these
are your early study your phase study
designs phase 3 study designs the large
efficacy trials we talked about
recruitment and adherence sample size
and power since we're at Stanford and we
have people who have developed amazing
adaptive design so you will hear about
adaptive designs in designing your yours
clinical trials how to handle missing
data data analysis and interim
monitoring both from a statistical
perspective as well as the data
monitoring committee perspective so with
that I hope I've piqued your interest
and your appetite for clinical research
and epi and now to my wonderful
colleague dr. Suhani thanks dr. propel
that was actually a great lead-in to my
presentation because my courses focus
primarily on the statistics but it's so
important to keep the statistics in
context how were the data collected
where did those data come from
you can't interpret that the statistics
in a vacuum so I teach a 3 course
sequence in biostatistics for the
master's program in epidemiology and
clinical research at Stanford you see
that course numbers up there for the
certificate program you would take the
first two of those courses which is my
introductory and my intermediate
biostatistics courses so I'll just start
by talking a little bit about something
that dr. pope had alluded to which is
that you have to be skeptical of the
published literature and we have as many
of you are probably aware a
reproducibility crisis in science and
this has to do with many facets as dr.
propath earlier did to research design
how you design the studies is a key part
of that I'm gonna focus of course more
on this tattoo
tics but that's it's all important this
is one of my favorite studies that came
out in 2005 by Johnny Anita's who is
actually now a faculty member in the
division of Epidemiology at Stanford and
he published a paper called why most
published research findings are false
and he was pointing out that a lot of
the findings in the literature actually
are false positives spurious
associations that can arise either
because you do a study with bias or
because of the study design or because
of the statistics or all three of those
if you like late night television as I
do you may have caught there was a John
Oliver piece a couple of years back on
just dealing with talking about this
whole reproducibility crisis so you see
this in even in the media and the
popular media right now there's been a
couple of high-profile cases I'll just
point out here so there is a case with a
scientist a high-profile scientist at
Cornell who does food science his
research have been highly cited talked
about in the media and his research has
come under scrutiny for a number of
reasons one of which is a sloppy data
handling something we're going to try to
I'll talk about with you in my classes
to try to help you to do not have sloppy
data handling another issue is a lot of
his researchers research findings seem
to have come out of what's called key
hacking so what that means is if you
parse your data in enough ways if you
kind of try all possible associations
with all the variables in your data set
you are going to find some spurious
associations some things that achieve
statistical significance P is less than
0.05 but those are almost certainly
going to be false positives and that's
one of the things we talk about in my
classes is trying to avoid P hacking
I'll just put up a few more this was a
some an article that was in five thirty
eight.com this was actually something I
was involved in there was a statistical
method introduced into the sports
science literature that causes high
false positives some of you may have
read in New York Times or other media
outlets about some famous research on
power poses in psychology that's been
discredited again a lot of these things
have to do with poor study design as
well as poorly done statistics and so
what I tried to do in my classes is to
teach you how to do reproducible
research and to do good statistics I
blame some of the issues with poor
statistics in the literature on how we
teach statistics and I'm not saying that
all statistical teaching is bad I think
there's some great statistical teaching
that gob goes on out there but I noticed
that a lot of statistical teaching seems
to fall in one of two camps the first
approach is a perfectly valid a method
this is how I was trained
but it's highly theoretical with a lot
of math so a lot of calculus linear
algebra and proofs not so much practical
training on how to deal with data and
again I love this kind of stuff I like
to do proofs one of those equations up
there is from one of my papers from this
year but this approach is not
appropriate for every audience so people
who are doing Applied Sciences in
psychology education medicine may not
need to know all of the math and may not
need to work out all the calculus if
their goal is really just to analyze
their data properly and if you try to
teach it in this way and it's not a
match with the audience sometimes what
ends up happening I've noticed is that
we swing to the other extreme so instead
of teaching all the math we suddenly
teach none of the math and you end up
with more of a cookbook approach and
that's approach that I find really
problematic so because when you end up
taking out all of the math it becomes
more of a I just have some data I want
to know how to get it in the statistical
analysis program and get something out
click the right buttons and get results
and I think this is a problematic way to
teach statistics and also to do
statistics it leads to some of the
reproducibility issues that I was just
talking about because if you are just
kind of throwing your data into a
statistical black box not really
understanding what's happening in that
box and what the results mean that come
out unfortunately this leads to all
sorts of problems and one of the
problems is that if you are kind of
fuzzy on what exactly is
coming out of that black box it's too
easy to cherry pick out of the results
that come out and I'm not saying
scientists do this intentionally I think
it's mostly unintentional but if you
kind of fuzzy on what those results mean
it's very easy to just kind of select
the ones that seem to support the story
that you want to tell and then get
excited about that story and publish a
story that is misleading I'll just give
you one of the example of this this is
something I was looking at recently this
is a from a published paper and they
were looking at glucosamine which is a
supplement that sometimes people take
for knee osteoarthritis which is pain
and stiffness that you get in your knee
as you grow older and they randomly
assigned it was a randomized trial was a
small randomized trial thing was about
50 people and they randomly assigned
have to take a glucosamine
supplementation have to take a placebo
pill now if you looked at the the
published study there was no graphical
representations of the data they simply
put all the data in a table and I was
looking carefully at that table and
noticed something and so I do quite a
bit of statistical sleuthing as Rita
said we have to kind of be a detective
and I really enjoy statistical sleuthing
so I actually just pulled the data out
of the table and graphed it myself there
were two primary outcomes for this study
the pain that you have in your knees and
your disease severity sort of an overall
disease severity so I'm going to show
you my graphs this is the data that I
just took out of tables and I simply
graphed it and what you're seeing here
is the graph of pain the y-axis is the
percent change since baseline you want
it to go down because you want pain to
get better and the x-axis is time in
weeks this was a 24 week study the blue
line is the treatment group the red line
is the placebo group and you do not need
to know any calculus or have a degree in
math or statistics I think to interpret
this graph correctly I think we can all
look at that and agree that there was
maybe some small decrease in both groups
if anything the placebo group went down
more in pain than the treat
group and actually those two lines are
sort of within the statistical margin of
error of each other so really there's no
difference showing up between those two
groups the author's actually the paper
got that right as I'll show you in a
minute they got the right conclusion
with pain we're things went wrong is
when it came to disease severity which
is some kind of scale people figure fill
out to say how bad their disease is
flaring up again we want it to be lower
just take a second here and look at that
graph same general graphic treatment is
in blue placebo is in red and take a
second and see what conclusions you
think you would draw from that graphic I
think all of us kind of looking at that
would probably agree that doesn't look
like there's much difference between
treatment and placebo in fact they ended
up after 24 weeks at almost the same
level of disease severity in fact you
can see there's some drop in disease
severity and this indicates that there's
some kind of placebo effect going on so
it's a subjective measure people take a
pill and when you take a pill sometimes
you feel better just from the placebo
effect so that seems to be what we're
seeing here the only real difference
that you can see between the two groups
is probably just due to chance
fluctuation they have a slightly
different trajectory so for some reason
might be just chance the treatment group
went up a little before it went down and
then kind of was level whereas the
placebo group went down a little and
then up and then went down but they
ended up in the same place so it might
surprise you to hear that what I would
consider a null result within the paper
the authors put a positive spin on it
and in fact this has comes right out of
the abstract they say these results
suggest that the consumption of the
glucosamine the supplement for 12 weeks
or longer has a positive effect on
osteoarthritis score osteoarthritis
score is that disease severity score I
was just showing you now they got it
right on pain in contrast it does not
reduce pain so let's look at that
graphic again how in the world is that a
positive effect the placebo group in the
treatment group basically did the same
it doesn't seem to be any benefit from
treatment and I think it's easy to see
in the graphic so what happened here I
think this is one of those cases where
the authors took their data they stuck
it in the
computer program they were happy to get
out some results in in the midst of all
those results there were a few
significant p-values and I'll tell you
there was a significant p-value the drop
from four weeks to twelve weeks in the
treatment group happened to be a
significant decline but guess what the
drop in the placebo group from 12 weeks
to 24 weeks was also a significant
decline they didn't make a story out of
that but there was a true decline here
there was an actual placebo effect
people did feel a little better
subjectively there was also a
significant p-value there's a technique
called repeated measures ANOVA and when
you plug those data into that you do get
a significant p-value that significant
p-value though just tells you that the
trajectory the the lines the paths those
two groups took was a little bit
different as you can see visually here
it does not tell you however that the
treatment group beat the placebo group
unfortunately if you're not quite sure
what these statistical methods are doing
you see those significant p-values you
get excited you make a story that's
false
so I'm going to teach you in my courses
some principles of effective statistics
one of the most important things I think
is that you can't do statistics well
without understanding the basics of
probability and statistical inference
you can't do statistics without any math
now that doesn't mean we have to swing
to the extreme of putting in a ton of
calculus in linear algebra I believe
that most of what you need to know in
statistics can be taught with
subtraction multiplication division you
may also need to be familiar with like
decimals and fractions but that's the
level of math that's required in my
classes you also need to use common
sense around numbers I'm gonna try to
teach you what is statistical inference
what is probability and a good strong
understanding of those but you don't
need the fancy math necessarily for that
and one of the techniques that I use for
teaching is computer simulation we will
do a lot of computer simulation so I'll
just give you an example of that there's
a lot of problems that can be solved
mathematically but can also be solved in
a computer and so one of the classic
probability problems that you're gonna
see in any sort of probability 101
course is called the birthday
and it goes something like this I mean
you may have heard of it before
imagine you have a class of 30 students
what's the probability that in a class
of 30 students that two people at least
two people are gonna share the same
birthday like they were both born on
August 7th and instinctively most of us
think that that probably is gonna be
pretty small right there's 30 people and
there's 365 different birthdays
surprisingly though that probability is
quite high it's in a class of 30 there's
actually a 70% probability that two
people will share a birthday um you can
solve that problem mathematically and
for those of you who are interested I
will solve it mathematically in my
course for you but you can also solve
that problem with computer simulation
and I think the computer simulation is
really intuitive and what you do we have
great computing power these days so you
can do this on a laptop in a second you
actually have the computer randomly
sample 30 birthdays out of all possible
365 366 if you include leap years
birthdays and you have a computer do
that a arbitrarily large number of times
so like a hundred thousand times pure
can do this in a second you look then at
all of those samples and you look at the
birthdays and see and how many of those
samples was there a match you have the
computer count out up in all of those
different 30 classrooms out of a hundred
thousand times how many times did you
get a match and that will give you the
exact same answer as if you solve it
mathematically so we'll do a lot of
computer simulation to help motivate
what's happening under the hood in
statistics another principle of
effective statistics is you need to
understand your data and so we don't
just stuff things into the statistical
black box and press the button to do a
t-test before you do that ninety percent
of your data analysis is actually not
doing the t-test or the linear
regression or getting p-values it's
actually drawing pictures with your data
understanding how much missing data you
have understanding where your data came
from making sure that you don't have
errors in your data and really just
getting a sense of what's going on in
your data before you ever run a formal
statistical test
I talked about drawing lots of pictures
of data you need to use common sense
always consider the totality of the
evidence don't just cherry-pick and
we're also going to talk a lot about
keeping an accurate record in code of
everything you do to the data and all
the analyses you do so that I mentioned
earlier the case of the scientists at
Cornell whose work has come under fire a
lot of that a lot of the problems have
to do with not keeping an accurate
record not being able to produce
datasets or code that back up an
analysis in a published paper so I teach
again two courses in the certificate
program in the fall you'll take HRP 259
that's my introductory course we will
spend quite a bit of time on the theory
of probability and statistical inference
a lot of that as I've already mentioned
we will do with computer simulation and
there will be some math of course you
have a choice you can work in either R
or SAS we use the free version of SAS
SAS University Edition R is also free
and you don't have to do the course in
both of those you're just gonna pick one
of those and I will teach you how to
code there is no prerequisite you it's
fine if you have never coded in either
one of those before if you want to learn
both you're welcome to try to learn both
we will also do the practical side of
data analysis how to think about look at
and describe data how to actually get
your data into R or SAS clean it
manipulate the data tape you know count
up the missing data and then how to
actually analyze it we will talk about
how to choose the right statistical test
how to run a regression how to interpret
the results from those statistical tests
properly we'll talk a lot about common
statistical pitfalls that underlie a lot
of the the reproducibility crisis in the
literature and I really enjoy being a
statistical sleuth so I will teach you
how to be a statistical sleuth my winter
quarter course is a mix of theory and
practice again we will continue to
analyze data in our SAS getting a little
bit more complicated in our coding I
will talk about some more advanced
regression techniques and things like
how to deal with correlated observations
and some more advanced techniques like
principal components analysis and
propensity scores and again we will
fundamentally
make sure that we're not hitting
statistical pitfalls and also we'll
learn how to be a statistical sloop and
that ends my portion so I'm gonna pass
it back yeah so thank you so much
Kristen Rita for this really informative
presentation and I hope all of us who
are here with us today can really walk
away feeling more confident and
knowledgeable about both of your work
and as well as kind of some of the
topics that are really related to
epidemiology and clinical research so
now let's move on to the Q&A portion of
this webinar so the first question that
we have you know for the both of you
really is really more about kind of you
know the the prerequisites so not in
terms of you know courses you know do I
need to take you know stats 101 or you
know maybe a senior level stats course
back in undergrad but more so about kind
of knowledge you know that you guys
think would be most appropriate before
coming into this program so that they
can get the most out of these courses so
if you can kind of just talk a little
bit more about prerequisites and
knowledge that will be great sure I can
I jump in so there are new prerequisites
in terms of you do not have to have had
a previous that's course and you do not
have to have experienced coding and our
SAS we will teach you all that as I
alluded to you have to be comfortable we
had basic math decimals fractions
nothing too complicated and it's helpful
I think to have some context so if you
are somebody who's doing research and
you're familiar with the medical
literature that doesn't mean you have to
be an expert on it but you maybe read a
medical paper or you know are involved
in research that and contacts does
provide sort of the basis and the
motivation to take our courses yeah so
for the methodology courses there are no
prerequisites I think having some
familiarity with having at least read
and occasional scientific paper is
helpful and if you've taken a stats
course of course that's helpful in terms
of content you know we are within a
School of Medicine we are our examples
tend to be very clinically focused but
we have students all across campus who
take our classes so we have students
from engineering or you know some other
discipline who may not know enough about
medicine and
when we first bring up examples it oh my
gosh do I need to know what Parkinson's
disease is like no you don't you know
what's the wiki for Wikipedia oh no you
don't need to know the principles apply
broadly across and you don't need to be
an expert in biology and neuroscience or
anything you can come from pretty much
you know any background and benefit from
this material and be able to get value
from the courses great well that I hope
that's that was really helpful for all
of you so the second question that we
have is you know based on your knowledge
what is approximately the time
commitment that's related to some of
these courses so because a lot of our
audiences are working professionals or
are full-time students so how much time
do you think they would have to dedicate
to successfully complete the courses in
the workload okay well there's always
gonna be arranged but yeah so I think in
terms of and by the way for those
students or the participants who are
asking these questions you're not alone
in fact in our master's program
substantial number of students are
actually fellows and residents or
medical students who have who are
juggling several responsibilities what
we've done is so in terms of you know in
class time for example 225 and 251 we
meet twice a week so that's three hours
of in-class sort of participation or
watching the video of course there's
gonna be homework assignments so I would
say in addition to the three class time
hours maybe another three again this is
the range it could go from one to maybe
five hours depending on how familiar you
are and how in-depth you also want to go
so yes I would agree that you know five
to six hours might be per class is a
probably a good target we you should
know that we both Rita and I designed
all of our courses around a physician
audience of working physicians who have
to go to clinics several days a week so
we have designer courses to be very
comprehensive but also efficient to help
to save you time for my courses all of
the lectures are on
is about two hours of lectures including
the lectures on programming each week
and then of course there's some reading
that you could do alongside sometimes
you may need to watch a video twice if
it's a maybe a more complicated
probability question so it might be
three out and then I also have class
time where we spend doing solving
problems so again it might be about
three hours of lecture and sort of class
exercises and then however much you want
to prepare beyond that I have a weekly
homework there are some online quizzes
so you might be about three hours I
would say it would be a good target but
there will be a range depending on your
comfort level with math and familiarity
with these topics great well so the
question that we have moving forward and
I think this was actually a really
popular question from our participants
it's a lot of them are actually thinking
about maybe using this as a stepping
stone into a ph.d program so can you
kind of further elaborate on you know
how some of those content and the course
could potentially help them pursue a PhD
in the field and what you recommend this
course are you know who are taking it
for that purpose yeah I would think that
I mean students in our ph.d program take
some of our courses of these same
courses and let's say that you know you
want to do a PhD and you sometimes
people pursue a master's first but let's
say you're don't want to necessarily do
a full master's first you could get a
lot of the beginning content through
these four courses that would be a good
foundation to up to one to know if you
really want to continue into a PhD in
this area and also to have a good
foundation to do a PhD absolutely yeah I
think it depends of course on your
background so if you have you know I'm
assuming that you want to pursue a PhD
in this field or something that would be
related to that would require these
skills in which case as dr. Shahani said
I think kidding hmm it's just the
subject material really is of interest
to me do I get excited by it would be a
wonderful opportunity and then of course
to also test the waters and
see how comfortable you are with the
material and whether you can really
challenge yourself you know within the
domains of statistics and methodology as
you apply for for a ph.d program great
so on that note you know we also have a
few students and participants here who
you know are asking about kind of
academic help you know throughout this
process as most of these courses are
going to be offered online so will day
receive kind of you know the same
academic support from the professors
from the teaching team and how will that
process be kind of carried out
yeah I'm we will treat you as any other
student in our courses so you are
considered a student of course as we see
you on our same enrollment less than two
the additional thing we're gonna do for
the online course is because of the
issue of remote being remote in some of
the in-class activities that we do are
very hands-on I think both for my
courses and dr. poppa's courses so we
will have a TA who is the liaison to the
remote students to help make sure that
those activities that you're trying on
your own were normally we walk around
the classroom and sort of look at your
code and oh you're missing a semicolon
there that there's a similar experience
for the remote students by having a TA
was dedicated to that yeah definitely I
think we're we are committed to
supporting the students who are doing a
certificate program in the same way that
we're committed to our students who are
on campus so we will make sure that
there are TAS who can provide the help
and assistance well kind of office hours
also be available for students who are
remote that's a great question yeah I
have a normal Monday office hour and we
may have to figure out how that exactly
works is we won't be in real-time with
the students so we will have another
office hour option for that yeah oh also
the office hours are taped so if you
wanted it sometimes students just come
to get help on the homework and then
often if you have the question somebody
else who actually comes to the office
everyone you answer the question to some
of my on-campus students actually don't
come to the office hours but watch the
video and then
can get the questions answered so I
don't tape my office hours so but we
make sure that you know a TA is able to
respond to your questions and I'm you
know we'd be available as well great and
now it's time for a kind of a lot of
people's favorite question you know
really about the outcomes right like
what am I gonna get out of this program
what type of career paths and you know
employment options would be available to
me so just based on your experience of
teaching this course here on campus in
the classroom so what type of career
routes and paths to do students usually
take after completing these classes so I
can couple of examples so I'm talking to
now necessarily not in the physicians I
don't know if actually we didn't get a
chance to see the poll results from the
first Bowl so I don't know what
backgrounds our participants come from
but I assume this question is from those
who are not clinicians our clinicians in
the making and I think one of the there
are actually two or three that come to
mind to you know three groups one being
so if you are involved if you're a
research coordinator and you want to do
actually more not just recruit patients
and help with the day-to-day functions
of a clinic or a lab then having these
skills you can be more involved in the
and assist the PI and actually helping
them develop protocols as well as
setting up databases and even helping
with statistical analysis you know to
look at sort of preliminary data and so
on so that's one area another area is if
you come from the writing world medical
science journals this would of course be
immensely helpful the third group is if
you are say working at a biotech company
so chiliad Genentech these
pharmaceutical companies often have
epidemiologists who are on their teams
and often what the epidemiologists have
to do is to actually see what's out
there what's been published what's the
disease burden and they have to actually
do sort of a systematic review of the
existing
evidence and these skills will help you
sort of add to the kinds of things that
you can just do in these roles I think
the skills that we teach are largely
foundational skills I mean they're in a
particular area about medicine but data
science is a huge field right now being
able to analyze data in our SAS and
understanding the implications of where
the data come from that's a transferable
skill against across a lot of fields
right now right and if I may actually
doctor said out he just reminded me so
let's say you're someone who just comes
from a biostats background you did a
master's in bio stats I think because
often the statistics just sits in a silo
learning about the methodology and how
to actually approach the data analysis
what we constantly tell our students is
that the statistical program is just a
tool as and we don't want people just
using they're using it as a black box so
how to think about analyzing and
thinking about the approach that's
informed by what the methodology was and
what the measurements are are the skills
that we do teach and actually dr. sonali
and i have been teaching this fall for a
decade and so I pretty much know what
she covers and she knows what I cover
and it's a very nice complementary sort
of teaching sort of partnership yeah
yeah and this question is specifically
you know for dr. tsunami so we have a
participant I asked about you know how
rigorous really is the statistics
portion of this program so are we gonna
be dealing some of the more advanced
topics you know including kind of
imputation and hidden Markov models and
such so I would say it's it's very
rigorous in the sense of that I want to
start in the foundations and I want you
to do data analysis properly so you're
gonna document your code you're gonna
understand the models my HRP 259 courses
largely focuses on that so we don't
necessarily get beyond regression
analysis we focus on doing statistics
right and I actually think that once you
have that the particular statistical
test that you're gonna run that's easy
to look up online and figure out how to
do it in
so I think the foundational stuff is
much more important in my upper my
second of course we cover some more
advanced topics we don't cover Monte
Carlo simulation or we I yeah I cover a
little bit about imputation we talk
about missing data imputation dr. pop
had also talks about that in her courses
we don't get into it in a in a like a
very very deep way but I would say the
courses are are quite rigorous and that
you are expected to not just be able to
do those and implement those but really
understand the foundations that build up
to those yeah I think we do have courses
in place so you know right I teach one
in the spring but it's not part of the
certificate program so I think you need
to as dr. sacani says once you have a
good foundation pretty much and you know
these statistical techniques you have to
be aware are gonna keep developing in
fact we have to constantly educate
ourselves about what's the new method of
doing you know X wires right and once we
know the basics and you look up the
papers and you read them and then
usually the code is available and right
I teach a lot through computer
simulation and I'll tell you if a new
statistical method that I learn I find
oh I got a rundown on my data first
thing I do is pop it into the computer
and run a simulation so I have a sense
of I I have some data which I understand
the generation of the data I put it in
this testicle method then I can
understand the pluses and minuses of
that method so the the particular
methods to me in the way are less
important than knowing how to assess
them and how to understand what's going
in and out of those methods I also need
to know sorry this is the benefit of
mine because there'll be a new thing
like instrumental variables or even
propensity score matching and yeah these
techniques are all sophisticated and
fancy but sometimes it's overkill and
sometimes it's something cycle of it you
actually you can do in a simpler way and
they're just trying to make it great so
now I know we're getting a little bit
close to two twelve o'clock so we have
time for two last questions so the
second to last question that I have here
is really about you know since
of course kind of focused more on kind
of clinical you know medicine rate like
just in a more traditional sense well
any of the courses cover a kind of
alternative medicine and clinical
research or integrative medicine via
examples so again our course is not
specific that it is you has to be
clinical or public health I think the
principles broadly apply if you're
interested in community research if
interested in alternative medicine
integrative medicine great I love it but
you can use the tools to evaluate these
yeah you know alternative therapies in a
rigorous way so that actually I think we
need to see more rigorous research in
that domain so so we are examples you
certainly see them right We certainly
have a broad range of students on campus
I think it's not that's it you know I
have some from engineering from
psychology from education and so for
them the specific examples may not be
exactly in their domain but that's okay
they're applicable across great so the
last question that we have today and you
know I'm sorry that we still have 50 or
so questions you know from all of our
participants I would love to address but
we only have time for one last one here
so the last question that that came from
participants is that what type of
resources would you recommend them at
kind of exploring you know between now
and and perhaps September so that they
can kind of prepare for the content for
the course you know if there are any
resources that you would recommend like
Bullock's or web sites or courses kind
of more entry-level courses that it can
you know seek out outside of Stanford
perhaps your move yeah that's a good
introduction then you could check some
of that out as an introduction you don't
feel don't feel like you need to do a
bunch of homework before you come to us
we we start from step one if you want to
download our or SAS university edition
and play with both of those and figure
out which one you prefer or maybe do a
little research about different areas of
research people will use SAS and some
people use are so kind of figure out
what people around you are using so you
can make that choice that might be one
of these things to do for homework
actually that's a great suggestion and I
am more comfortable in SAS so that's
what I'm tend to use
and in my courses of course we won't be
using it that much for methods but SAS
University Edition has wonderful
tutorials and video you know recordings
of how to download it how to use it so
it's a good idea to play around and
again we'll provide good colleague right
now who is currently in the moment
taping some introduction videos on how
to download our and so you don't don't
feel like you have to do that but if you
want if you want to be prepared and do a
little bit about ahead time they'll just
make your first week easy great perfect
so thank you so much again you know Rita
Kristen for answering all the questions
from our participants and for really
great and informative Q&A session so we
are at top of the hour right now you
know it's about a minute until 12:00 so
unfortunately we won't have time for any
additional questions but if you'd like
to learn more about this program please
don't hesitate to reach out to us
directly our contact information is
available on our website as listed on
the slide that you see in front of you
and also make sure to check your inbox
for the webinar recording within the
next week and you'll also have an
opportunity to reach out directly to us
as well so thank you again dr. Koh Pat
and dr. zinati for joining us today and
we wish all of you the best as you
pursue your education goals and academic
endeavors thank you for joining us
you